[Music]
in the stage
for the Angel Band and the park goes
missing in between their hands and
quietly we walk with a feeling of love
it's getting hotter I know
but I will walk with you till the night
falls away
through the sorrow we got well I know
you see it coming
we were always running we were always
there we're the friends
[Music]
we're cold
it's getting harder I know
I will sing with you till the night and
I Falls away
through the darkness we go well I know
you see it come
[Music]
down under the stream and the engine's
hanging to the beat of Dreams
[Music]
it's getting darker I know
it falls away
is the time this weekend
well I know you see it come
[Music]
I have a tired will
the clear enough
[Music]
to let the sweetness in
to see your joy
that is
[Music]
and we always will and there's always
it's getting darker oh I know
it falls away
Darkness we go well I know you've seen
it coming
[Music]
[Applause]